IN HIS NEW MEMOIR, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SECRETARY OF
STATE, MIKE POMPEO, SUGGESTING
THAT NIKKI HALEY SCHEMED WITH
J
JARED KUSHNER AND IVANKA TRUMP
ABOUT REPLACING MIKE PENCE AS
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
NIKKI HALEY IS WEIGHING IN,
TELLING FOX NEWS IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> POMPEO EVEN SAYS HE'S NOT
SURE IF IT'S TRUE.
I NEVER HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
JARED, IVANKA OR THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THE VICE PRESIDENTSHIP.
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU IS IT'S SAD
WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO OUT AND PUT
OUT LIES AND GOSSIP TO SELL A
BOOK.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE SAID IT.
BUT THAT'S WHY I STAYED OUT OF
D.C. AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO GET
AWAY FROM THE DRAMA AND THE
GOSSIP.
I DID NOT SPEAK WITH ANYONE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THAT AT
ALL.
IT WAS GOSSIP.
MIKE PENCE IS MY FRIEND.
IT WAS NEVER DISCUSSED.
IF SOMEBODY ELSE DISCUSSED IT,
THEY CERTAINLY DIDN'T DISCUSS IT
WITH ME.
IT'S JUST GOSSIP.
THIS IS ALL GOSSIP.
THERE'S NO TRUTH TO IT.
AND MIKE SAYS IN HIS BOOK IT'S
JUST GOSSIP.
>> JOINING US NOW ANA NAVARRO
AND MAGGIE HABERMAN.
>> JUST GOSSIP.
>> I WOULD BE WORRIED WITH A
DRINKING GAME WHERE THE WORD WAS
GOSSIP.
>> I THINK IT'S CLEAR HE'S
TAKING SHOTS AT MAYBE 2024
RIVALS.
>> HE WRITES ABOUT HER, JOHN
BERMAN --
BOLTON, HE GENERALLY SPARES THE
PERSON FOR WHOM HE WORKED OTHER
THAN A PASSING GLANCING BLOW IN
A COUPLE OF PLACES ON A COUPLE
OF KEY ISSUES.
HE'S WRITING THIS BECAUSE HE IS
LOOKING AT THE FIELD AND SEEING
WHAT IS COMING.
I WILL SAY THESE RUMORS ABOUNDED
IN REAL TIME.
YOU REMEMBER THIS, I REMEMBER
THIS, FOLKS AROUND KUSHNER AND
IVANKA TRUMP DENIED IT.
I WILL SAY SHE'S NOT WRONG IT'S
SURPRISING TO SEE A FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE WHO SPENT A
LOT OF TIME ATTACKING THE MAIN
STREAM MEDIA FOR CREDIBILITY
WRITING I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS
TRUE BUT I'M PUTTING IT IN MY
BOOK ANYWAY.
>> THAT IS FASCINATING.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT'S JUST
GOSSIP OR DO YOU THINK THERE'S
TRUTH TO IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO OF THESE TWO
TO BELIEVE, FRANKLY.
I THINK YOU NEED TO PUT
SOMETHING GOSSIPY IN BOOKS IN
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT GETS THE
COVERAGE.
WHAT I FIND FASCINATING IS THE
AMOUNT OF FORMER TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PEOPLE, INCLUDING
THE VICE PRESIDENT, THE U.N.
AMBASSADOR, THE FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE, WHO ARE ACTIVELY
PUTTING ON -- ACTIVELY GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF PUTTING
ON A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN OR
NOMINATION CAMPAIGN DESPITE THE
FACT THE GUY THEY WORKED FOR HAS
ANNOUNCED HE IS RUNNING.
>> INTERESTING.
>> SO THE LITTLE EFFECT THAT
DONALD TRUMP'S ANNOUNCEMENT HAS
HAD IS ASTOUNDING TO ME GIVEN
THE SUPPORT HE ONCE HAD.
AND THE LOYALTY WE THOUGHT HE
HAD.
>> LET ME FOLLOW-UP WITH MAGGIE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IT'S -- THAT
THERE'S SOME TRUTH TO THIS?
>> I THINK IT IS VERY POSSIBLE
THAT THERE IS SOME TRUTH TO
THIS.
I HAVE NO PROOF, NO WAY OF
KNOWING FOR SURE.
I KNOW WE WERE HEARING LOTS OF
TALK ABOUT TRUMP FLOATING THE
IDEA IS PENCE LOYAL.
WE KNOW THAT RUPERT MURDOCH AND
JARED KUSHNER WAS TALKING UP
NIKKI HALEY TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND A FRIEND OF TRUMP'S WROTE A
COLUMN HOW HE SHOULD REPLACE
PENCE WITH NIKKI HALEY.
AND I KNOW A FRIEND THAT CALLED
A FRIEND AND COMPLIMENTED HIM ON
THE COLUMN.
SO THERE ARE ENOUGH DOTS TO
BELIEVE IT.
BUT I'M NOT MIKE POMPEO I'M NOT
SAYING IT'S TRUE.
>> MIKE POMPEO WAS SUGGESTING IT
IN HIS BOOK BRINGING JOHN KELLY
INTO IT.
IT DOES RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
NIKKI HALEY RUNNING IN 2024.
SHE WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS SHE
SAID IF TRUMP RUNS I'M NOT GOING
TO RUN.
NOW SHE'S SAYING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
>> I HAD A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU IS THE
SURVIVAL OF AMERICA MATTERS AND
IT'S BIGGER THAN ONE PERSON.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA, I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR A NEW GENERATIONAL
CHANGE.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO BE 80
YEARS OLD TO BE A LEADER IN D.C.
I THINK WE NEED A YOUNG
GENERATION TO COME IN, STEP UP
AND START FIX THINGS.
IF I RUN I'M RUNNING AGAINST JOE
BIDEN IF I'M THAT PASSIONATE AND
DETERMINED, WHY NOT ME?
>> SOUNDS LIKE SHE IS HEAVILY
CONSIDERING A RUN.
>> THAT WAS NOT SUBTLE.
THAT WAS QUITE ANTITHETICAL TO
WHAT SHE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE,
NOT RUNNING IF DONALD TRUMP WAS.
>> WHO IS NIKKI HALEY?
>> THAT'S BEEN A QUESTION THAT I
THINK HAS BEEN LOOKED AT FOR A
WHILE, SINCE SHE WAS GOVERNOR.
SHE WAS PRETTY CRITICAL OF
TRUMP, REMEMBER, IN 2015.
WHEN HE WAS, YOU KNOW, MAKING
ALL KINDS OF INFLAMMATORY
STATEMENTS.
>> AND FLYING THE CONFEDERATE
FLAG OFF THE STATE HOUSE.
>> AND SHE WENT TO WORK FOR HIM
AND DEFENDED HIM REPEATEDLY.
AND THEN CRITICIZED HIM WHEN HE
WAS OUT OF OFFICE AND THEN TRIED
TO BACKTRACK.
SO WHO IS NIKKI HALEY IS A
QUESTION IF SHE RUNS IS A
QUESTION THAT'S GOING TO BE
ASKED.
>> SHE'S ALWAYS CONTRADICTING
HERSELF AFTERWARDS.
WHEN EVER I HEAR NIKKI HALEY,
THE SONG PLAYS IN MY HEAD, WILL
THE REAL NIKKI HALEY PLEASE
STAND UP.
>> WHAT DOES SHE STAND FOR?
>> I'M TELLING YOU, SHE STANDS
FOR WHATEVER IS CONVENIENT AT
THE MOMENT.
WHEN SHE GETS BLOW BACK, SHE
PULLS BACK.
WE SAW IT HAPPEN ON JANUARY 6th,
DURING THE JANUARY 6th, YOU
KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
JANUARY 6th AND HER, SHE WAS
CRITICAL, THEN WENT AND
APOLOGIZED, AND THEN THIS.
SHE'S BEEN ALL OVER THE PLACE ON
SO MANY ISSUES.
AND IN THE MEANTIME, THOUGH,
SHE'S ON CORPORATE BOARDS AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT NIKKI HALEY
TODAY IS A LOT BETTER OFF
FINANCIALLY THAN SHE WAS BEFORE
BEING IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO SHE'S BEEN ABLE TO REALLY --
SHE HAS BEEN ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT
HAVING GREAT BLOWBACK, WITHOUT
BEING TAINTED AS SOME HAVE BEEN,
AND MONETIZING ON IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT SHE'S BEEN
ABLE TO MONETIZE ON THAT
POLITICALLY.
>> THERE COULD BE AN OPENING FOR
HER IF SHE COMES OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION UNSCATHED AND IS
ABLE TO USE THAT IN A FORMIDABLE
PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
>> MAGGIE YOU HAVE NEW REPORTING
ON A CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ACTBOUT ALL WEEK, WHICHS
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN AND
EVANGELICALS.
NOW HE'S CRITICIZING PROMINENT
LEADERS WHO AREN'T RETUSHING TO
ENDORSE HIM.
>> AS DISLOYAL, HIS FAVORITE
WORD.
WE HEARD HIM SAY THIS ALL THE
TIME AND NIKKI HALEY WAS ONE
NAME I ASKED HIM ABOUT WHEN I
INTERVIEWED HIM FOR MY BOOK AND
HE TALKED ABOUT DISLOYALTY.
IT IS A RISKY GAME THAT HE IS
PLAYING.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO HIM.
I WANT TO CAVEAT THAT OFF THE
BAT.
IF THERE'S MOVEMENT IT'S GOING
TO MAKE IT COMPLICATED FOR
EVANGELICAL LEADERS.
BUT RIGHT NOW HE'S THE ONLY
DECLARED CANDIDATE AND THEY ARE
GRATEFUL TO THINGS HE DID IN
OFFICE BUT THEY HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS.
IT WAS NOTABLE, ROBERT JEFFERS
HOSTED MIKE PENCE LAST WEEK.
JEFFERS IS STILL SOUNDING
PROTRUMP BUT THE FACT HE WAS
WILLING TO OFFER PENCE AN
AUDIENCE I THINK TELLS YOU
YOU'RE SEEING A SHIFT AWAY FROM
TRUMP.
WILL IT BE ENOUGH?
I DON'T KNOW WE'VE SEEN VOTERS
MOVE FROM LEADERS AND TOWARDS
TRUMP BEFORE BUT THERE'S A
SOFTENING.
>> I'M GETTING DEJA VU ALL OVER
AGAIN.
I REMEMBER AFTER THE "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" TAPES WHEN THE
EVANGELICAL LEADERS STEPPED
AWAY.
WHEN IT WAS CLEAR HE WAS THE
NOMINEE THEY STEPPED UP BEHIND
HIM.
I ALSO THINK YOU'RE FEELING THE
ABSENCE OF JERRY FALL WELL.
>> I AGREE.
>> HE'S SITTING BY A POOL
CURRENTLY IN MIAMI.
SO I THINK HE WAS 100% LOYAL TO
HIM.
THAT'S A BIG VOID THAT'S BEEN
LEFT IN EVANGELICAL LEADERSHIP.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I UNDERESTIMATED
TRUMP AND THE EVANGELICALS IN
2016 AND I WOULD WARN PEOPLE NOT
TO DO THAT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE SEEING IT FROM OTHER
POLITICIANS.
YOU'RE SEEING IT FROM DONORS.
YOU'RE SEEING IT FROM
EVANGELICAL LEADERS.
THAT THEY ARE TOYING WITH THE
IDEA OF SOMEBODY OTHER THAN
TRUMP.
THEY ARE INDICATING THEY WANT
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN TRUMP.
BUT IF IT IS TRUMP THEY'RE GOING
TO LINE UP BEHIND HIM LIKE HE
ONCE DID IN 2016.
>> IF HE'S THE NOMINEE THEY LINE
UP BEHIND HIM.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE PRIMARY CAMPAIGN THAT HE'S
STILL THE ONLY DECLARED
CANDIDATE.
>> I'M STILL GETTING DEJA VU
BECAUSE OF THE REPUBLICANS ON
THE STAGE OPENING THE PATH.
>> CAN YOU PLEASE STOP BRINGING
UP THE "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE
NIGHT.
>> I WILL NEVER MOVE ON.
THAT AMERICA ELECTED THE MAN IN
THOSE TAPES I WILL GO TO MY